llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo a América por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Juan Pablo
lumi Juan Pablo Buenos días Buenos días
Andrés Juan Pablo empezamos en América
Latina con una noticia económica que se
conoció tarde en la noche de ayer
miércoles se trata del acuerdo comercial
entre Ecuador y China una firma con el
gigante asiático que llega Poco después
de que Ecuador haya desplazado a Estados
Unidos como su principal socio comercial
no petrolero la negociación tomó 10
meses y ahora el tratado permitirá
liberar de aranceles para el ingreso a
China de manera inmediata hasta un 50
por ciento y es que pese a no tener un
documento comercial firmado previamente
en 2022 el comercio bilateral ha tenido
un crecimiento constante entre estos dos
países evidentemente hasta alcanzar en
2022 los 12.000 295 millones de dólares
con esto Ecuador se convierte en el
cuarto país de la región en firmar un
acuerdo comercial con el gigante
asiático y se une a Chile Perú y Costa
Rica que ya un tratado de libre comercio
con Beijing a continuación leeremos más
detalles de este documento que publicó
en sus redes sociales el presidente del
país Guillermo lasso y lo vamos a leer
acá porque el documento dice en otra
buena noticia para el Ecuador hoy
firmamos el acuerdo comercial con china
que nos abre un mercado de 1400 millones
de consumidores el crecimiento de
exportaciones no petrolera será entre
3000 y 4 mil millones de dólares
adicionales a los que ya comerciamos el
99,6% de nuestras exportaciones entrarán
con un 0% de aranceles a el país
asiático fue lo que dijo el presidente
en sus redes sociales en cambio vamos de
tema porque Durante este jueves el
ministro de finanzas de Francia hizo una
dura advertencia al sector de alimentos
en ese país que dijo Juan Pablo el
encargado de la cartera económica
francesa Bruno le mearc amenazó este
jueves a los fabricantes de alimentos
lemer dijo que irías si era necesario a
la fiscalía si los fabricantes de
alimentos utilizaban impuestos para
recuperar el margen de que han perdido
en medio de la elevada inflación el
ministro dijo que los grandes
fabricantes de alimentos debían abrirse
a negociaciones comerciales y bajar los
precios al por menor y al tiempo que
descienden los precios al por mayor le
damos entonces las palabras del ministro
francés que dijo lo siguiente abro
comillas Si alguna vez la industria
alimentaria se niega a entablar estas
negociaciones cosa que evidentemente no
puede imaginar utilizaremos todas las
medidas a nuestro alcance incluido el
instrumento fiscal para recuperar los
márgenes que serían los indebidos
obtenidos a Costa de los consumidores
esto haciendo evidencia de que pues hay
una inflación elevada y que las personas
que están vendiendo pues tienen esas
pérdidas y él está previniendo de que
pues no hagan estos ajustes como lo dice
él de manera indebida y pues afecta a
los consumidores al final Juan Pablo
vamos a seguir allí en Europa el banco
de Inglaterra subió sus tasas de interés
este jueves De cuánto fue el aumento de
25 puntos básicos un incremento que
exacta es Exactamente igual al que la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos y el
Banco Central europeo pero en Reino
Unido genera un panorama distinto Porque
con este aumento las tasas fueron
elevadas al 4,5% llevando Los costos de
endeudamiento a su nivel más alto desde
2008 y siendo esta la décima segunda vez
que incrementa los tipos de forma
consecutiva revisaremos Entonces ahora
el dato de inflación anual de Reino
Unido porque dependiendo la inflación
Andrés es que pues también se toman
decisiones sobre las tasas de interés y
lo veremos a continuación la primera
economía de la Unión Europea del
continente Alemania con un 7,2%
interanual Estos son datos de abril el
dato de eurozona que lo estuvimos
revisando aquí un 6,9 Francia tiene un
dato menor que sorprendió teniendo en
cuenta que hay una crisis política
también una crisis en el país en
diferentes escenarios España un 4,1
mucho más bajo que los tres anteriores
pero en el caso de Reino Unido tenemos
el dato de marzo que es interanual y
está todavía por encima del 10% se
esperaba que en este mes llegara por lo
menos
una cifra o a un dígito pero todavía
sigue por encima por los dos dígitos y
precisamente pues esto es lo que pone
presión sobre el banco para que las
tasas de interés aumente bien y de
Europa pasamos a China Juan Pablo porque
hay una situación de control Estatal a
las empresas extranjeras en ese país y
es que grupos empresariales han
denunciado que se han desplegado
investigaciones por parte del gobierno
Chino Sobre el manejo que las empresas
le dan a la información algo que han
señalado como un exceso de control y ha
generado incertidumbre sobre cómo operar
en China eriksen presidente de la cámara
de comercio de Estados Unidos dijo el
martes que estaba preocupado por los
informes de las empresas de diligencia
debido a que habían sido atacadas por
las autoridades en diferentes redadas ya
que su trabajo es esencial para hacer
negocios en China y es que los grupos
empresariales han denunciado de estas
redadas por parte de la seguridad
nacional en diferentes firmas de
consultoría destacadas mientras china
señala que debe cuidar cómo estas
empresas pues son que son externas
tratan la información y pues trata como
de blindarse a todo lo externo que llega
el escenario para analistas económicos
Se presenta como un desafío para el
objetivo del gigante asiático de querer
reactivarse económicamente porque dice
Bueno quieren la reactivación económica
pero le están poniendo límites a las
empresas con estas ruedas ahora un
panorama más difícil para el gigante
asiático Así es Juan Pablo y finalizamos
con Los indicadores Y entonces empezamos
con el cierre que es con América Latina
en donde sus indicadores pues estuvieron
mixtos el único que tuvo una pérdida
fuera indicador de Perú cuando cayó un
1,74% para el caso de Argentina Brasil y
chile tuvieron ganancias pero ninguna
alcanzó Más allá del 1% si nos vamos a
revisar las bolsas europeas que Todavía
siguen operando de sus tres principales
indicadores el único que está reportando
ganancias es el indicador de París esto
teniendo en cuenta lo que estábamos
hablando ahora del ministro de economía
pero Londres y Frankfurt tienen pérdidas
en el caso de Londres por el dato de las
tasas de interés que sigue con el
incremento y pues este es su incremento
número 12 consecutivo y ya veremos cómo
será el dato de inflación en ese país
Juan Pablo locumí Muchas gracias Nos
vemos entonces en unos minutos con una
actualización de las noticias económicas
ahora con mucho más Andrés